the opening scene is so great and i  remember yeah so distinctly first of all  judy greer is fantastic and we knew her  from arrested development i remember on  that day that was not scripted that  charlotte  charlie has all the hats and all the  clothes on and he didn't tell anybody he  was doing it i distinctly remember and  it was a reveal  and so d d d walks over and the camera  just pans over charlie's full-on  laughing or at least smiling i remember  being behind the monitors and laughing  yeah he's kind of big that's what i'm  sure i was just doing for you guys being  like all right let's see if i can throw  them off here  and  it's the stat it's the stack of hats and  the stack of hats  i don't know really who this character  is but he's in my mind from somewhere in  my childhood but like do you remember  the great gazoo  he was like a cartoon character i don't  know some big brain like alien guy  and uh i was going for a great kazoo